If you would, would you walk us through a typical day for you? This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vittantham. Today, we're talking about finding meaning in our work. I generally come in at least 15 minutes late. I use the side door, that way lumber can't see me. And after that, I just sort of space out for about an hour. Space out? Yeah, I just stare at my desk, but it looks like I'm working. This clip from the movie Office Space describes what work feels like to many people, not the stuff of poetry. But now imagine something
如果你愿意的话，能为我们介绍一下你典型的一天吗？这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。今天，我们来谈谈如何在工作中寻找意义。“我通常至少迟到15分钟。我走侧门，这样木材（主管名）就看不见我了。在那之后，我就发呆大约一个小时。”“发呆？”“对，我就盯着我的办公桌，但看起来像是在工作。”电影《办公空间》里的这段片段描述了许多人对工作的感受，这可不是什么诗情画意的东西。但现在，想象一下某种
that feels more than just a job, something that feels like a calling. What we learned is people who see their work as a calling are significantly more satisfied with their jobs, they're significantly more satisfied with their lives. They're more engaged in what it is that they're doing and tend to be better performers regardless of what the work is. This week on Hidden Brain, a conversation with Amy Riznowski, professor of organizational behavior at the Yale School of Management. Amy studies work and something that she calls job crafting. Job crafting can help you make the job that you have right now,
感觉不仅仅是一份工作，而是一种使命感的东西。我们了解到，那些将工作视为使命的人，对工作的满意度要高得多，对生活的满意度也高得多。他们对自己所做的事情投入度更高，而且无论工作内容是什么，往往表现也更好。本周在《隐藏的大脑》节目中，我们将与耶鲁大学管理学院组织行为学教授艾米·瑞兹诺斯基进行对话。艾米研究工作，以及她所称的“工作重塑”。工作重塑可以帮助你把你现在这份工作，
more meaningful and more satisfying. Amy Riznowski, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. I was reading one of your papers recently and I was struck by an excerpt that you had at the top. One came from a corporate securities lawyer and one came from a tax adermist. And I was struck by what the two of them said.
变得更有意义、更令人满意。艾米·瑞兹诺斯基，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。我最近在读你的一篇论文，被你开头的一段摘录深深吸引了。一段来自一位企业证券律师，另一段来自一位标本剥制师。他们两人的话让我深受触动。
Can you tell me what they said? Sure. So the corporate securities lawyer was bemoaning the fact that his job as he saw it was, I think his words were a deal with the devil, that he did the job not because he liked it, but because it allowed him to stay geographically in an area that worked for his family and so on. And in contrast, the taxidermist was talking about the way in which the kind of work he did, sometimes moved people to tears when they came
你能告诉我他们说了什么吗？当然。那位企业证券律师在哀叹他的工作，在他看来，我想他的原话是“与魔鬼做交易”。他做这份工作不是因为喜欢，而是因为它能让他留在地理位置上适合他家庭的地方等等。相比之下，那位标本剥制师谈到了他所做的工作有时会让人热泪盈眶，当他们来
and picked up the pieces that he had created for them and how for him the feeling of satisfaction that comes from work that has that kind of impact is one of the biggest things in his life. I have the paper in front of me that taxidermist said, I did a duck for a guy the other day. And when he came and picked it up, he almost started crying because it looked so nice.
取走他为他们创作的作品时，对他来说，那种因工作产生的影响而带来的满足感是他生命中最重要的事情之一。我手头就有这篇论文，那位标本剥制师说：“前几天我为一个人做了一只鸭子。当他来取走它时，他几乎要哭了，因为它看起来太漂亮了。”
He was just so happy. And that made me feel good that he thought I'd done a good job. Self-satisfaction is a big deal in any job. It's a big deal in life. And I was so moved by that comment, because of course, if you just looked at those two jobs side by side, you might assume that the corporate security's lawyer with the high profile fancy job is the person who's actually happier at work, but that's not often the case.
“他非常高兴。这让我觉得很好，因为他认为我做得很好。”自我满足感在任何工作中都是一件大事。在生活中也是如此。我被那段评论深深打动了，因为当然，如果你只是并排审视这两份工作，你可能会认为那位拥有高调、体面工作的企业证券律师在工作中会更快乐，但事实往往并非如此。
That's not often the case. And in fact, a good amount of the research that I've done has tried to look at how the experiences that people have in their work, the ways in which they talk about it and come to think about its place in their lives, vary so much across the entire spectrum in ways that research hasn't necessarily recognized. When you went into a hospital some years ago and you looked at the people working as the cleaning staff of the hospital, you discovered something very interesting. You found that they did not all think of their jobs the same way.
事实往往并非如此。事实上，我所做的大量研究都试图观察人们在工作中的经历，他们谈论工作的方式以及他们如何看待工作在生活中的地位，这些在整个范围内差异巨大，而这种差异在研究中并不一定被认可。几年前，当你走进一家医院，观察那些在医院做清洁工作的人时，你发现了一些非常有趣的事情。你发现他们并不是都以同样的方式看待自己的工作。
That's true. And our first clue about this was not necessarily in how they talked about the ways that they thought about the job, but in how it was that they described the tasks of their job. So on the one hand, we have this group of hospital cleaning staff members who described the work as being not very high skill. And another group who described it in very different terms, and said this was highly skilled work, where it would be very difficult to bring others in and have them take over the job.
确实如此。我们关于这一点的第一个线索并不一定在于他们如何谈论自己对工作的看法，而在于他们如何描述自己的工作任务。一方面，我们有一组医院清洁工，他们将工作描述为技术含量不高；而另一组则用完全不同的术语来描述，称这是高技能工作，如果让其他人来接手这份工作会非常困难。
And in looking to see what were the differences between these two groups of cleaners, we had no differences in the kind of shift that they worked. They're tenure in the organization, the kind of units they worked on and so on. Instead, what was different was what they described as being the kinds of things that they did during the daily course of the work. So in the first group, the cleaners who described the work as being not particularly high-skilled, they very much hude to the job description. The job description, while extensive, doesn't involve a lot of interaction, in fact, any interaction, with patients, visitors, nurses, doctors, and so on.
在观察这两组清洁工之间的区别时，我们发现他们在轮班类型、在组织中的任期、工作的部门等方面都没有区别。相反，不同之处在于他们描述自己在日常工作中做的事情。在第一组中，那些认为工作技术含量不高的清洁工，他们非常严格地遵守工作描述。工作描述虽然广泛，但不涉及与病人、访客、护士、医生等人的大量互动，实际上是没有任何互动。
Presumably they were just swabbing floors, dusting, mopping, doing cleaning crew type stuff. Exactly. In the second group, they also talked about all of these kinds of things, but in addition, talked about the kinds of things that they did on a regular basis, for and with nurses, doctors, patients, and patients, visitors. And we checked this multiple times, but this was not something that they were being asked to do. Often, these kinds of things were going beyond the notice
据推测，他们只是在擦地板、除尘、拖地，做清洁工类型的工作。完全正确。在第二组中，他们也谈到了所有这些事情，但此外，还谈到了他们经常为护士、医生、病人和病人家属所做的事情。我们多次核实了这一点，但这并不是要求他们做的事情。通常，这些事情超出了
of those who supervised them in the hospital in which they worked. But for the cleaners who engaged in this, we ended up calling this job crafting. They were crafting the boundaries of their jobs in ways that we think made the work for them more meaningful, was something that they very much undertook on their own. If I remember correctly, some of the people who found their work especially difficult were in fact doing work that might be argued to be against the rules. Yes, so some of the things that the cleaning staff members
他们在医院工作的监督者的注意范围。但对于参与其中的清洁工，我们最终称之为“工作重塑”。他们以我们认为使工作对他们更有意义的方式重塑了工作的边界，这是他们非常主动去做的事情。如果我没记错的话，一些觉得工作特别困难的人，实际上做的工作可能被认为是违反规定的。是的，我们样本中这一部分的清洁工
in this part of our sample describe doing involved figuring out when would it be safe, for example, to give a patient a drink of water if they requested one, or when for example, to give a patient a drink of water if they requested one, or when was it safe to help a patient to move or things like this, which moves into the realm of patient care and could very well get them into trouble. But the cleaning staff members we studied had developed systems of figuring out when was it safe to do these things.
所描述的一些事情涉及弄清楚什么时候给病人喝水是安全的（如果他们有要求的话），或者什么时候帮助病人移动是安全的，诸如此类的事情，这进入了病人护理的领域，很可能会给他们带来麻烦。但我们研究的清洁工已经形成了一套系统，来判断什么时候做这些事情是安全的。
One was it okay to do these things versus when would it be necessary to go and get a member of the medical staff? You found one woman in particular who did something really interesting when it came to patients who were in a coma. Tell me what she did. So this particular staff member worked in a, essentially a long-term rehabilitation floor
什么时候做这些事情是可以的，而什么时候有必要去叫医务人员？你发现其中一位女性在对待昏迷病人时做了一些非常有趣的事情。告诉我们她做了什么。所以这位特定的员工在一家基本上是长期康复的楼层工作，
where patients were unconscious or comatose and hopefully would be emerging from those states. One of the things that she described doing was taking down the framed art prints, most patient rooms have some kind of print or another, and she would take those down on a regular basis and rearrange them and re-hang them. And when we asked her if this was part of her job or part of the duties that she was given in her job description, she answered that it was not, which was quite striking. And in asking more deeply about, well, why do this? Talked about the hope that even though
那里的病人处于无意识或昏迷状态，希望他们能从这些状态中恢复过来。她描述的一件事是取下装裱好的艺术印刷品（大多数病房都有某种印刷品），她会定期取下它们，重新排列并重新挂上去。当我们问她这是否是她工作的一部分，或者是否是她工作描述中给出的职责的一部分时，她回答说不是，这非常引人注目。在更深入地询问“为什么要这样做？”时，她谈到了希望，即使
patients were not necessarily aware of their surroundings, maybe some shift in the environment in which they were recuperating could spark something in them and speed their trajectory of healing. In some way she was behaving like we would behave toward a family member. You're trying to anticipate the needs of the person even before they're expressed. You're not following the letter of the law, you're actually trying to do everything you possibly can to ensure an outcome for someone you care about. Absolutely. And we saw a lot of evidence of this in our data. So cleaning staff members who talked about getting in the room sort of aiming their face sort of skyward to look at the ceilings of the hospital rooms to see if there were
病人不一定意识到周围的环境，也许他们康复环境中的一些变化能激发他们的一些东西，并加快他们的康复进程。在某种程度上，她的行为就像我们对待家庭成员一样。你试图在对方表达需求之前就预见到他们的需求。你不是在照本宣科，你实际上是在尽你所能确保你关心的人获得好的结果。绝对是这样。我们在数据中看到了很多这样的证据。所以那些谈论进入房间的清洁工，会把脸朝向天花板，看看医院房间的天花板上是否有
things that were up there that we might not notice, but would bother the patients if the patients had to look at them all day long so that they could take care of any dirt or sort of issues up on the ceiling. And we also heard a lot from the cleaning staff members about looking at each patient, and in many cases patients' families, as though, well, this could be my father or my mother or my brother or sister, and how would I care for them? So there's two ways to look at these people who are doing things that are outside of their job description.
我们可能不会注意到，但如果病人整天盯着看会让他们感到困扰的东西，这样他们就可以处理天花板上的任何污垢或问题。我们也从清洁工那里听到了很多关于观察每一位病人，在许多情况下还有病人的家属，就好像，“这可能是我的父亲、母亲、兄弟或姐妹，我会如何照顾他们？”所以看待这些做着超出工作描述范围事情的人，有两种方式。
You could call it at one level, you know, a form of insubordination. They're basically not following the rules at all. And you could say these are trouble-bakers and we want to make sure that we have as few of them as possible on the staff. But you can also see them as people who are going the extra mile and really internalizing the larger mission of the hospital and not just the descriptions of their jobs. What did you find in terms of the outcomes of having workers who are the one kind or the other? Well, in this particular context, we were only gathering data about what it was that the hospital cleaning staff members said they were doing and then what was that related to with respect to their experience on the job. We can only speculate as to what the outcomes were likely to be, but I would expect, for example, that particularly in a medical context,
你可以在一个层面上称之为一种“不服从”。他们基本上根本没有遵守规则。你可以说这些人是“麻烦制造者”，我们希望确保员工中这样的人越少越好。但你也可以把他们看作是付出额外努力的人，他们真正内化了医院的更大使命，而不仅仅是他们工作的描述。在拥有这两种员工的结果方面，你发现了什么？嗯，在这种特定的背景下，我们只是在收集关于医院清洁工说他们正在做什么的数据，然后看看这与他们在工作中的体验有什么关系。我们只能推测结果可能是什么，但我会预期，例如，特别是在医疗环境中，
that it's hard to imagine that this wouldn't have had some kind of positive effects, because a lot of the things that the hospital cleaning staff members were talking about had to do with, you know, in the course of their cleaning work, noticing who hadn't had a visitor in several shifts, who looked like they might be on the in several shifts, who looked like they might be on the verge of tears, who seemed like they really needed to talk, so that they could finish with their work and double back to spend time with those patients or with those patients' family members.
很难想象这不会产生某种积极的影响，因为医院清洁工谈论的很多事情都与以下情况有关：在清洁工作的过程中，注意到谁在几个轮班中都没有访客，谁看起来可能处于崩溃的边缘，谁看起来真的很需要交谈，这样他们就可以完成工作后折回来，花时间陪伴那些病人或病人的家属。
And it's hard to imagine that that kind of work doesn't have a positive impact in a context like that. I want to talk about what these different kinds of initiatives mean for the workers, but I want to just spend one second again looking at it from the point of view of the patient, which is that I think all of us, in some ways, have been in the shoes of those patients. May not be, you know, patients in a coma at the hospital, but we've been students in a class or, you know, going to the DMV to get a driver's license. And all of us have routinely encountered people who are there just doing their jobs and there because they really find some deeper meaning in their jobs. I remember a chemistry teacher that I had in high school. I wasn't particularly fond of
很难想象这种工作在这样的环境中不会产生积极的影响。我想谈谈这些不同类型的举措对员工意味着什么，但我还是想花一秒钟从病人的角度来看待它，因为我认为我们所有人，在某种程度上，都曾处于那些病人的位置。可能不是医院里昏迷的病人，但我们曾是班里的学生，或者去车管所领取驾照。我们所有人都经常遇到那些只是在做工作的人，以及那些因为在工作中找到了更深层意义而工作的人。我记得我高中时的一位化学老师。我并不是特别喜欢
chemistry but the teacher was so inspired by the fact that chemistry was just the coolest subject in the universe that he communicated some of that excitement and enthusiasm to me and I knew that he wasn't just doing a job teaching me chemistry. This was something he desperately and deeply wanted to do. And I feel like all of us have these experiences. And when we come in contact with these people, we feel like we are now in touch with the higher purpose of what this organization is supposed to be about.
化学，但那位老师被“化学是宇宙中最酷的学科”这一事实所激励，他向我传达了一些那种兴奋和热情，我知道他不仅仅是在做一份教我化学的工作。这是他迫切且深深想要做的事情。我觉得我们所有人都有过这样的经历。当我们与这些人接触时，我们会觉得我们现在接触到了这个组织应该有的更高目标。
I think that's very well put, very well said, and I completely agree. And in fact, the line of research I was involved in that led to this study originally started with exactly this question, how do people who are doing exactly the same job and the same organization come to see that work in such radically different terms, where some of them see it as you put it as just a job, versus seeing the work perhaps more as a career. And then finally, people for whom that exact same work is something more akin to a calling. And these differences have always fascinated me where they come from, what the implications
我认为这说得非常好，非常到位，我完全同意。事实上，我参与的研究方向最初就是从这个问题开始的：在同一个组织中做完全相同工作的人，是如何以如此截然不同的方式看待那份工作的？有些人像你所说的那样，将其视为“仅仅是一份工作”，而另一些人则将其视为“职业”。最后，对于那些人来说，同样的工作更像是“使命”。这些差异一直让我着迷，它们来自哪里，对做这份工作的人以及他们所属的组织意味着什么。
are for the individuals who do the work and for the organizations that they're a part of. In the second half of my conversation with Amy, we talk about what you can do to feel more engaged at work. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Today, I'm talking with Amy Riznowski about how we can find meaning in work. I asked Amy what she'd found about people who think of their work as a calling. What we learned is people who see their work as a calling are significantly more satisfied with their jobs, they're significantly more satisfied with their lives.
在我和艾米对话的下半部分，我们谈论你可以做些什么来让自己在工作中感到更投入。请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。今天，我正在与艾米·瑞兹诺斯基讨论我们如何在工作中寻找意义。我问艾米，关于那些将工作视为使命的人，她发现了什么。我们了解到，那些将工作视为使命的人，对工作的满意度要高得多，对生活的满意度也高得多。
They work more hours, they miss fewer days of work, they're more engaged in what it is that they're doing. So when we look at these two different kinds of people in the workplace, and I think what we often say is, this person just happened to find the organization that suits him or her, that it's just happenstance and luck that people find their calling. What I find really interesting and intriguing about your work is that you suggest that they might actually be a more deliberate process involved so that more of us can find our
他们工作时间更长，缺勤天数更少，对自己所做的事情投入度更高。所以当我们审视职场中这两种不同的人时，我认为我们经常说的是，这个人只是碰巧找到了适合他或她的组织，人们找到自己的使命纯属偶然和运气。关于你的工作，我发现真正有趣和引人入胜的是，你暗示可能实际上有一个更深思熟虑的过程，这样我们更多的人就能找到我们的
work to be a calling. It's a wonderful contrast that you draw here because I do think that there are two different schools of thought in play around callings. And one is that it's out there. You have to find it. It's a matter of moving into the right role or the right position and the right organization and so on. And then suddenly this will be unlocked.
工作作为一种使命。你在这里做出的对比非常精彩，因为我确实认为关于使命有两种不同的思想流派在起作用。一种是它就在那里。你必须找到它。这是一个进入正确的角色、正确的职位和正确的组织等等的问题。然后突然之间，这就会被解锁。
And your work will be this sort of joyful end in and of itself, which is very different from a view that I've come to, which is that can certainly happen, where people can stumble into something and realize this is what I would do, even if I hit the lottery, versus how is it that I can craft the boundaries of this job, and the way that I think about its role, in the world, in such a way that I can come to experience, perhaps, as something that is meaningful in a way that potentially a calling could be. One of the interesting things that happened recently is that we had this major power
你的工作将成为一种快乐的终点，这本身就是目的，这与我得出的观点非常不同，即这种情况当然会发生，人们可能会偶然发现某件事并意识到“即使我中了彩票，我也会做这件事”，而不是“我该如何重塑这份工作的边界，以及我如何看待它在世界中的角色，从而使我能够体验到它，也许，作为一种在某种程度上可能成为使命的有意义的事情。”最近发生的一件有趣的事情是，我们有了这个大型强力球
ball lottery that a lot of people got excited about. And our CEO at NPR bought everyone in the company lottery tickets and so we spent the day speculating what would be like to win $200 million. But what I found most interesting was that we asked several people, would you quit your job if you won this money? And I found it very revealing what people's answers were. So some people unhesitatingly said, of course, I'd quit my job. Why in the world would I keep working if I had $200 million
彩票，很多人对此感到兴奋。我们在NPR的首席执行官给公司的每个人都买了彩票，所以我们花了一天时间猜测赢得2亿美元会是什么样子。但我发现最有趣的是，我们问了几个人：“如果你赢了这笔钱，你会辞职吗？”我发现人们的回答非常有启发性。有些人毫不犹豫地说：“当然，我会辞职。如果我有2亿美元，我为什么要继续工作？”
in the bank? And other people had exactly the opposite response, which was sort of a complete bewilderment. Why in the world would I quit my job when I'm doing something that I really enjoy doing? And I think it speaks exactly to what you're saying here. The people who are working because the work is an end in itself and the people who are working because the work isn't means to an end. I think that seeing that divide and seeing that for even in the same exact job that the
而另一些人则有完全相反的反应，这是一种完全的困惑。“当我做着我真正喜欢做的事情时，我为什么要辞职？”我认为这恰恰说明了你在这里所说的。那些工作是因为工作本身就是目的的人，以及那些工作是因为工作是达到目的的手段的人。我认为看到这种分歧，并看到即使在完全相同的工作中，
work can mean such different things to different people doing that work often with the same level of education, same level of pay and so on is fascinating to me. And I think, you know, given the choice, I think what we're seeing now is many people as they grow up and it's time to, you know, come to think about what they want to do in their work are yearning for something that will feel a bit more like a job that you wouldn't necessarily want to quit if you hit the lottery. But I think that that's depending on your theory of how these things work. If you think it's a magical unicorn out there that you just have to find, I think that that can be quite anxiety provoking for people.
工作对做这份工作的人来说意义也可能如此不同，通常具有相同的教育水平、相同的薪水等等，这让我着迷。而且我认为，你知道，如果有选择的话，我认为我们现在看到的是，许多人在成长过程中，当需要考虑他们想在工作中做什么时，渴望的是一种感觉更像是一份如果你中了彩票也不一定想辞掉的工作。但我认为这取决于你对这些事情如何运作的理论。如果你认为它是一个你只需要找到的魔法独角兽，我认为这会让人们感到非常焦虑。
So a finding one of these great jobs is not one of these magical things that happens, or it is a magical thing that can happen, but it's also something that can be crafted, as you suggest, what's the way to do it? Well, I mean, I think that part of what is involved is thinking about what kinds of things do people feel they very much enjoy and that they think are important in the world, whether those are tasks that have to get done because they help the world function in a way that is a real benefit to society or to other people to see how and where might you start to do things to make that work your own in a way that could feel even more fulfilling.
所以找到这些伟大的工作并不是这些会发生的魔法事情之一，或者它是一件可能发生的魔法事情，但它也是可以被重塑的，正如你所建议的那样，方法是什么？嗯，我的意思是，我认为所涉及的一部分是思考人们觉得他们非常喜欢什么，以及他们认为在世界上什么是重要的，无论是那些必须完成的任务，因为它们帮助世界以一种对社会或其他人真正有益的方式运作，还是看看你如何以及从哪里开始做事情，以一种可能感觉更充实的方式让这份工作成为你自己的。
You've also looked at efforts to try and change what it is the job itself is. So you get hired for a job, you're maybe a typist or maybe you're a computer programmer or you're maybe a manager, but then you can start working to expand the contours of what the job description actually is. Yes, one of the things that's interesting that I want to point out is that it's not only about expanding what those boundaries are and taking on more and doing more job crafting can also involve
你也研究过试图改变工作本身是什么的努力。所以你被雇佣做一份工作，你可能是一名打字员，或者你可能是一名计算机程序员，或者你可能是一名经理，但随后你可以开始努力扩展工作描述的轮廓。是的，我想指出的一件有趣的事情是，这不仅仅是关于扩展那些边界并承担更多和做更多的工作重塑，工作重塑也可以涉及
restricting that boundary, if you will. So maybe delegating or even pulling back or dropping some of the tasks that may be defined as part of the job, that over time people perhaps come to realize are not actually central to getting done or executing on the kinds of things that the organization feels that they ought to be responsible for. Now a lot of people feel like they don't have the latitude to make those changes, that I'm stuck. My manager won't allow me to modify what I'm doing. There are ways that I can see I can be more productive and more useful to the organization, but I feel constrained and hemmed in. Those are real concerns.
限制那个边界，如果你愿意的话。所以也许是授权，甚至退后一步，或者放弃一些可能被定义为工作一部分的任务，随着时间的推移，人们可能开始意识到这些任务对于完成或执行组织认为他们应该负责的事情并不是核心的。现在很多人觉得他们没有做出这些改变的余地，觉得我被困住了。我的经理不允许我修改我正在做的事情。我可以看到我可以更有效率、对组织更有用，但我感到受限和束缚。这些都是真实的担忧。
They absolutely are. And even in jobs where this kind of crafting is explicitly forbidden, you still see people engaging in it. And I think it usually works like this. You recognize what it is that the organization expects you to accomplish. And you see, where do you have the degrees of freedom that you might take advantage of to do that in a way that maybe from a process point of view or from how you order the tasks point of view or who you interact with to get that work done point of view, how you can essentially customize that in a way that makes the experience more enjoyable, more meaningful, and something that perhaps makes you feel more connected
它们绝对是。即使在明确禁止这种重塑的工作中，你仍然看到人们在进行这种重塑。我认为它通常是这样运作的：你认识到组织期望你完成什么。然后你看看，你在哪里拥有可以利用的自由度，以一种可能从流程角度，或者从你安排任务顺序的角度，或者从你与谁互动以完成工作角度，以一种可以本质上定制它的方式，使体验更愉快、更有意义，并且某种程度上让你感到更紧密地联系
to those who you're either working with or who are the recipients or beneficiaries of your work. I'm also fascinated by the fact that you point out that it's not just crafting your job description that can allow you to find work that's a calling, but it's also Recrafting or redefining the relationships you have with other people in the workplace. Can you talk about that for a moment? Most jobs involve some level of contact with or interdependence with other people whether those are
与那些你正在与之共事的人，或者那些是你工作成果的接受者或受益者。我也对你指出的一点感到着迷，即不仅仅是重塑你的工作描述可以让你找到作为使命的工作，而且还可以重塑或重新定义你在职场中与他人的关系。你能谈谈这一点吗？大多数工作都涉及与他人的某种程度的接触或相互依赖，无论是
co-workers, whether those are clients or customers. It's often these relationships and these interdependencies with other people on the job that are the sources of the greatest joys and the greatest frustrations. And so in some sense doesn't surprise me that part of what it is that people are crafting are exactly that element. So the relationships and the interactions that are either necessary to executing the worker just come part and parcel with the doing of the job? You also talk in your research about the idea of cognitive crafting that besides changing the description of the job and the nature of the relationships around the job, there's also the way you think about the job, which in many ways is perhaps the thing you have the greatest control over, you have some ability to change what it is you're doing in how you come to think about what you're doing. Yes, so the third form of crafting, so you can craft the tasks that comprise the job,
同事，还是客户。通常正是这些关系和与工作场所中其他人的相互依赖，是最大快乐和最大挫折的来源。所以从某种意义上说，人们正在重塑的正是这一要素，这并不让我感到惊讶。所以这些关系和互动要么是执行工作所必需的，要么只是工作的一部分？你在你的研究中也谈到了“认知重塑”的概念，即除了改变工作描述和工作周围关系的性质之外，还有你思考工作的方式，这在许多方面也许是你拥有最大控制权的事情，你有能力改变你正在做的事情以及你如何看待你正在做的事情。是的，所以重塑的第三种形式，你可以重塑构成工作的任务，
the relationships and interactions that are part of the job, but this third category that you name cognitive crafting consists of how it is that people think about what the work even is. And it turns out that there's a lot of freedom in this, if you will, to go back to the hospital cleaning staff study. One of the questions that we asked the hospital cleaning staff members we interviewed was to give us your job title here. And some of the people in that study gave us their official technical title.
作为工作一部分的关系和互动，但你命名的这个第三类“认知重塑”包括人们如何思考工作本身是什么。事实证明，如果你愿意的话，这里有很多自由，回到医院清洁工的研究。我们采访的医院清洁工被问到的问题之一是“请告诉我们你在这里的职称”。研究中的一些人给了我们他们的官方技术职称。
Other people would say things like, I'm an ambassador or in the most extreme case of someone sort of deviating, if you will, from describing the work, the way that the organization would said, I'm a healer. One of the things that excites us about the job crafting work is that these different ways of engaging in cognitive crafting seems to be related to how it is that people actually then go about executing the job, right? If you have that uniform on and you're on your shift and you are thinking of yourself as a healer, that that is your responsibility and your role there.
其他人会说诸如“我是大使”之类的话，或者在某人偏离描述工作方式的最极端情况下，组织会说“我是治疗者”。关于工作重塑工作，让我们感到兴奋的一件事是，这些不同的参与认知重塑的方式似乎与人们随后实际执行工作的方式有关，对吧？如果你穿着那套制服，你在轮班，你认为自己是一名治疗者，那么这就是你的责任和你在那里的角色。
It's very different from thinking about it in terms of working through a particular task set in a day. And again, sort of where those differences come from, why some people do this, why others don't. And the difference that it makes for them is something that's been endlessly fascinating for us. Amy Riznowski, thank you for joining me on Hidden Brain today. Thank you so much for having me. It's been a pleasure. That's Amy Riznowski, professor of organizational behavior at the Yale School of Management. This week's episode was produced by Max Nestrak. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Parts Shah, Thomas Liu, Laura Correll and other Thiban LeMoodie. Our supervising producer
这与从一天中完成特定任务集的角度来思考它有很大不同。同样，这些差异来自哪里，为什么有些人这样做，为什么其他人不做，以及它对他们产生的影响，是我们一直感到无限着迷的事情。艾米·瑞兹诺斯基，感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。这是一种荣幸。那是耶鲁大学管理学院组织行为学教授艾米·瑞兹诺斯基。本周的节目由马克斯·内斯特拉克制作。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、雷娜·科恩、帕茨·沙、托马斯·刘、劳拉·科雷尔和其他蒂班·勒穆迪。我们的监制
is Tara Boyle. Our unsung hero this week is Steve Nelson. Steve works on the development of new shows at NPR and he always has good ideas for existing shows as well. We know that when we share audio with him and ask him for feedback he's going to have thoughtful suggestions for us. We also appreciate a sense of humor, usually delivered deadpan. If you're enjoying our U2.0 series please be sure to share it with friends and family. In next week's episode, we'll talk about why we sometimes stick our heads in the sand and what happens when we do.
是塔拉·博伊尔。我们本周的无名英雄是史蒂夫·尼尔森。史蒂夫在NPR负责新节目的开发，他对于现有节目也总是有很好的想法。我们知道，当我们与他分享音频并征求他的反馈时，他会为我们提供深思熟虑的建议。我们也欣赏他的幽默感，通常以冷面笑话的方式呈现。如果你喜欢我们的U2.0系列，请务必与朋友和家人分享。在下周的节目中，我们将讨论为什么我们有时会把头埋在沙子里，以及当我们这样做时会发生什么。
So when the stock market goes down, people check their portfolio less frequently than when the stock market is going up. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以当股市下跌时，人们检查投资组合的频率比股市上涨时要低。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。这里是NPR。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。